this is the second violent escalation
within the past 24 hours this time
around we've uh heard that up to five
rockets have been launched at the
airport of kabul where the united states
and uh some of its allies that's
remaining allies are still conducting uh
their evacuation uh from uh according to
reports from what we've heard uh a truck
a pickup truck with a concealed launcher
fired these missiles uh some distance
away
from kabul airport the rockets then were
shot down by point defense system so by
anti-air defense systems stationed at
the airport uh of kabul we haven't heard
any claims of responsibility nor nor
casualties that may potentially have
been caused nevertheless there has been
footage pictures showing showing fires
burning on the ground
in an area just outside the airport
perhaps they debris from
the rockets as they were shot down
previously we saw a us drone strike
conducted
just west of the airport in a
residential district just a few
kilometers west of the airport a drone
struck a vehicle that the united states
uh says was a vehicle-born ied device so
packed with explosives and that
allegedly isis was planning on using to
target the airport as they did just a
few days ago
this time there were multiple casualties
according to locals to journalists who
were at the scene nine civilians may
have been uh may have been killed among
them several children uh all related all
part of one family the united states
central command has reacted saying that
it's saddened to hear these reports
we are aware of reports of civilian
casualties following our strike on a
vehicle in kabul we are still assessing
the results of the strike which we know
disrupted an imminent isis k threat to
the airport we would be deeply saddened
by any potential loss of innocent life
tensions here in kabul which were
already incredibly high given the the
hectic pace of the evacuation the time
limit and the countdown
well the tensions exploded after the
terror attack three days ago at the
north gate of kabul airport where an
isis uh suicide bomber blew his vest
in the packed crowds right next to a a
checkpoint man by us troops and and
taliban fighters we heard that after the
explosion uh u.s troops began firing
into the crowds which were panicking
themselves and uh allegedly according to
doctors and witnesses most of the
casualties were caused by the ensuing uh
gunfire the uh the evacuation is he's
still continuing we heard throughout the
night uh jets
buzzing overhead uh endlessly cargo
planes carrying us troops as well as
those last lucky evacuees that have
managed to secure
passage being approved from evacuation
thousands tens of thousands of people
are still waiting
around the airport in kabul for that
elusive evacuation uh although at this
stage from what we've heard nobody from
outside the airport is is being allowed
into the airport for evacuation anymore
from what we've heard the united states
is now
evacuating those civilians that have
already made it that it is approved and
let into the airport the situation still
tense with with more threats more
attacks expected
against the airport
you